situé au coeur du continent africain le
tchad est le plus vaste et le plus
peuplé des états de l'ancienne afrique
équatoriale delmas il performant
transition entre les étendues
désertiques du sahara au nord est de la
savane soudanaise au sud le tchad ne
possède aucune façade maritime et se
trouve séparé de la mère par de vastes
territoires difficultés d'accès donc eux
qui en conservant au tchad de son
originalité lui ont donné le privilège
peu enviable de compter parmi les pays
les plus chers du monde
la tonne de ciment vos cinquante mille
anciens francs à fort lamy et cela se
comprend si l'on pense que les
marchandises débarquées à douala
allez go soit point thouars ont parcouru
des milliers de kilomètres par la route
ou par le fleuve avant d'arriver à
destination
géographiquement et arbitrairement le
pays peut se diviser en 3 grandes zones
au centre la zone sahélienne qui vient
mourir au bord du lac tchad au nord la
zone saharienne coupé par les massifs du
tibesti et de l'aîné dit au sud enfin la
zone de savane paradis des animaux et
des chasseurs
ces contrastes géographiques et la
position du tchad au carrefour de
l'afrique blanche et de l'afrique noire
explique la grande diversité qui existe
tant sur le plan ethnique et
linguistique que sur le plan religieux
au nord vivent les arabes et les foules
pays islamisés éleveurs nomades de peu
et de chameaux au sud par contre on rend
compte de nombreuses races négroïde
animiste catholiques ou protestants dont
les traditions sont pourtant restée
vivace encore que les [__] à
plateau est pratiquement disparu du
moins le diamètre des plateaux at il
diminué
c'est là dans le sud que d'yves lessard
un excellent agriculteurs et valeureux
combattants dont beaucoup ont servi dans
les rangs de l'armée 3,6 enfin sur les
bords du fleuve
on rencontre les kotoko célèbres pour
leur danse et leur pêche miraculeuse
c'est que le poisson qui est une grande
importance dans l'économie tchadien les
rives du chari et du logone constitue
une des zones piscicole les plus riches
du monde et chaque année les kotoko et
les bananas pêche cent mille tonnes de
poissons frais qui fut même séché seront
exportés vers la nigeria ou le cameroun
c'est dans les eaux du logone qu'on
pêche aux grands ennemis tel est le nom
de ses filets et qu'on pêche le salonga
sorte de harengs d'eau douce ou le
capitaine justement renommée pour la
finesse de sa chair poisson qui avait
que le sorgho et le mil constitue la
base de l'alimentation des populations
tchadiennes
oh
voilà donc ce pays ce peuple aux
origines diverses fractionné en
multiples groupes ethniques qui parle
des dialectes différents et qui est
pourtant unis par une longue tradition
de vie commune dans le cadre de l'ancien
keeper devenu un état indépendant
fortement centralisé sous la conduite de
son chef monsieur françois tombalbaye
mais justement les structures
traditionnelles ne sont elles pas les
plus fortes
l'antagonisme entre le nord et le sud at
il disparu
le chat at il fait sa révolution comment
le pays est passé du régime quasi
féodale imposé par les sultans à un
régime démocratique de type occidental
voilà les questions que j'ai posées à
fort-lamy à monsieur tombalbaye
sur le plan politique comme tout le
monde le sait il s'est toujours posé des
problèmes politiques à l'intérieur dé ce
qu'on appelait autrefois le territoire
français parce que la présence de
multiples leaders politiques tchadiens
de l'époque était à l'origine de cette
lutte tribales je crois pour ma part que
la chefferie où le sultan dans son
ensemble rocade à son existence qu'elle
représente
inna soupire traditionnelle et qu'il ne
fallait pas sous une forme ou sous un
prétexte de d'une nouvelle orientation
les supprimer brutalement
ceci étant dit j'ai suis arrivé à
montaut à intégrer également les chefs
les sultans dans l'ensemble de non pas
dans le parti progressiste mais dans
l'ensemble de l'évolution compte youtube
chad c sultan les voici
riche ou pauvre potentats régnant sur
des régions entières
ou bien droite les deux villages tous
ont conservé le décor fragile de leur
souveraineté gardées personnelles
serviteur courtisans musiciens sans
oublier les femmes du harem dont le
nombre est fonction de la richesse de
leur seigneur et maître
mais ce n'est là qu'un écho en fait
depuis l'abolition de l'esclavagé n'est
sultan sont devenus les auxiliaires de
l'administration
certains allant jusqu'à demander au
corps électoral
la ratification de leur autorité devenus
députés ou conseillers municipaux les
sultans ont ainsi permis au tchad de
passer sans trop de secousses du
moyen-âge au 20e siècle mais au xxème
siècle il faut produire sous peine d
perry l'économie du tchad ne se ramène
essentiellement à deux grandes activités
la culture du coton dans le sud et
l'élevage dans le nord
l'élevage de ces quatre millions de
boeufs et cinq millions de moutons c'est
aussi trois cent mille berger pour la
plupart nomades une grande partie de la
viande est exportée sur pied vers le
nigeria et le soudan mais depuis la
construction des abattoirs frigorifiques
de farcha dans la banlieue de fort-lamy
un tonnage important est exportée par
avion dans toute l'afrique et au sahara
bon an mal an les produits de l'élevage
représente pour les éleveurs tchadiens
un revenu de plus de 2 milliards
d'anciens l'autre richesse du tchad
c'est le coton traités sur place à fort
archambault
introduit au tchad dès 1929 et couvrant
maintenant 290 1000 hectares c'est la
seule culture vraiment industrielle de
ce pays le coton graine est débarrassé
de ses impuretés et transformé en fibres
emballé par balles de 200 kg de coton du
tchad est exporté dans le monde entier
production annuelle 98 mille tonnes de
graines qui donne 35 mille tonnes de
fibres fonds l'ami la capitale du tchad
n'était en 1920 qu'un petit village
c'est aujourd'hui une grande cité de
100000 habitants qui s'étale
paresseusement sur les bords du chat
malgré quelques immeubles modernes qui
abrite l'administration et le
gouvernement
la ville a su préserver son caractère
africain à la fois familiale et bon
enfant mais pour nous français fort lamy
ça n'est pas seulement la capitale du
tchad
c'est aussi un haut lieu de l'histoire
les départs d'une épopée dont les
tchadiens conserve le souvenir avec un
soin jaloux éboué leclerc de nom gravé
sur la pierre et dans les mémoires de
noms que l'on retrouve partout à fort
lamy avec les noms des victoires de la
france libre
non le tchad avec l'indépendance n'a pas
renoncé à son amitié pour la serrure en
témoigne éloquemment et monsieur
françois tombalbaye le proclame avec
force
il est évident que il n'y a rien qui
oppose le tchad à la france comme il n'y
a rien qui doit inquiéter la france à
l'égard du thème le cadre des tempes et
quand même à travers l'afrique
d'expression française car plus
d'anciens combattants c'est le pays où
il ya eu beaucoup de souvenir des
guerres et en donnent également que le
chat dans l'histoire dernière était la
première à répondre au général des
vosges et je souhaite que cette visite
symbolique donc la fraternité entre les
anciens combattants de nos deux pays
au nom de cette amitié et de fraternité
bienvenue en france monsieur le
président